c'est
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission minutes forme vous êtes avec
votre coach nicolas on est en présence
de jennifer bonjour 19 heures on vas tu
sais très bien je te remercie est prêt
pour le mouvement qui va arriver très
très bien je vais maintenant vous
démontrez le mouvement du pont de
possibilités une option facile et une
option plus difficile alors vous venez
vous installer dans un premier temps sur
le dos vous placez les bras le long du
corps
les épaules et la tête sur le sol vous
ramenez les talons vers les fesses et là
vous allez pousser vos hanches le plus
haut possible de manière à céret
volontairement les pertes en eau et
activer votre chiot janvier vous
descendez vous montez ça c'est votre
première option
seconde option vous allez tendre une
jambe et prendre appui sur un seul
client poussant sur votre talon vous
faites exactement la même chose d'une
ferme à l'autre bien entendu quand vous
avez terminé vous changé et vous passez
à l'autre à toi de jennifer sûr il n'ya
pas installé sur le dos blast et bras le
long du corps et ramène tes talons
proche de tes fesses
d'accord on a à peu près les étalons à
la largeur des hanches on va prendre
appui sur ses talons pour monter les
fesses le plus haut policier vas-y vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y très bien tu
redescends vas-y remonte et là on doit
se serrer ses abdos pour avoir un bon
maintien de la sangle abdominale et tu
dois sentir des fessiers et l'arrière
des cuisses travailler et tu vas partir
sur pas mal de répétition pour les
personnes qui découvrent ce mouvement je
vous conseille d'une dizaine ou une
quinzaine de répétition pour les autres
qui ont un peu plus d'habitude vous
pouvez faire des séries assez longue
vraiment ressentir la brûlure au niveau
musculaire
deuxième possibilité jennifer tu vas
attendre ta jambe très bien et tu vas
prendre appui seulement avec celle là
c'est exactement le même exercice
vous avez juste tout le poids du corps
elle précise sur une seule journée
on sent déjà la différence tu vas me
faire la même chose de l'autre côté
parfait et là tu pousses le déhanché
c'est d'avoir les amphibiens fixe serre
et et abdou pensez avoir une bonne
salade nominal pour un meilleur maintien
un meilleur positionnement pour exécuter
votre mouvement
très bien jennifer tu peu relâché te
remercie on va passer maintenant aux
étirements qui correspondent à cet
exercice
lorsque je vous conseille c'est nous
asseoir de fléchir une jambe de à passer
par dessus la jambe opposée
vous venez chercher l'extérieur de la
cuisse avec la main et vous tournez les
épaules de manière à étirer vos fessiers
la même chose sur les deux jambes
jennyfer gtc faire voilà tu va placer ta
jambe à g a cherché l'extraire de la
clis et syrie et là tu vas vraiment
sentir au niveau des fessiers
je maintiens une vingtaine de secondes
tu penses à respirer profondément et tu
relâches tout doucement on fait la même
chose de l'autre côté pensez à faire les
deux côtés bien entendu donne
rendez-vous dans les prochaines
émissions minutes forme
merci à tous a bientôt le compte les
sommes sollicités sont les fessiers les
cuisses et le bas du dos entraînez-vous
trois à quatre fois par semaine en
effectuant de trois à six séries de 15 à
30 répétition
attention à ne pas trop accentuer la
courbure lambert éviter de décoller la
tête du sol